we are joined by Nicholas Thompson
editor-in-chief of Wired and a CBS News
contributor Nick good morning good
morning so this is still going on
obviously for the people who were
infected do they have to pay the ransom
to get control of their computers or how
do they go about this well hopefully if
somebody has been infected they've got a
backup and they can just wipe their
computer and restore it that's your best
option but there is not a decryption key
that anybody's been able to circulate
yet so if you've been affected you are
in trouble Nick the US was not as
hard-hit as a lot of these other
countries why not well possibly the US
was a little more vigilant in order to
be hit someone inside of a system has to
click on a suspicious link has to click
on somebody one of those Google Docs
that you get sent where the English
isn't quite right and you don't know
whether you should click on it and also
you have to have not updated your
computers a lot of the computers that
were hit we're running Windows XP which
is 16 years old so it's either a very
old operating system or someone using a
more modern operating system where they
don't have auto updates turned on or
they haven't clicked that little thing
that's like install updates yes it can
be annoying at times what can you tell
us about the people that were targeted
the places that were targeted well the
most disgusting thing and this drives me
it's just repulsive is that so many
hospitals are targeted and you can see
why they would do that hospital
sometimes run old software they're not
as advanced in IT upgrading an operating
system at a hospital is hard because you
worry about the health records so a lot
of hospitals are running old operating
systems that haven't been upgraded and
not only that if you hit a hospital with
ransomware they're likely to pay because
they have heart surgery patients coming
in yeah so it's very people can even
have their surgery and it's just
terrible well I mean as Jonathan
Vigliotti mentioned in his story I mean
this exploited a vulnerability in
Windows but their Microsoft sent out a
patch for this apparently right and and
if people using their free antivirus
software were supposedly protected but
are you saying basically this is just
people who didn't update their systems
it's basically people who weren't
running auto-update or who hadn't
updated their systems right so this is
part of a vulnerability that the NSA had
found that was then stolen from the NSA
and leaked online in April criminals
took it and created this in May in March
Microsoft solved the problem and sent an
auto update so if you have Auto updates
or if you've installed all the proper
software you're okay you mentioned the
NSA breach what else might
have been taken in that been well we
don't know I mean fortunately because
all the stuff was dumped online in April
all of the companies whose
vulnerabilities were exposed presumably
have had time to upgrade themselves so
not only the NSA breach but also the CIA
documents that were leaked online so if
your Microsoft or your Apple or your
Google you've seen the vulnerabilities
or some of the vulnerabilities that are
circulating on the dark web and so
presumably you've patched your system
but what this means upgrade all your
operating systems go to your phone
upgrade the software go to your computer
upgrade the software these things have
been patched pheromone upgrade upgrade
upgrade backup your files don't click on
links right upgrade your software
Nicholas Thompson's message of the day